bonjour c'est cyprien et je voulais vous
parler d'une musique
le titre c'est le même que moi c'est un
duo entre un mec de 24 ans est un gamin
de 10 ans si vous connaissez pas c'était
le troisième single le plus acheté la
semaine dernière et le deuxième clip le
plus diffusé la télévision et si vous
connaissez toujours pas où chercher sur
google
comme tout le monde 1 j'aimerais vous
faire une petite critique
déjà dès la première seconde il ya un
problème ce mec d'or à billets ce type
est déjà celle où juste après dans le
clip le mec dit non non non je pense pas
no 1 qui aimeraient ressembler à un type
qui porte un chapeau pour se donner un
genre et une chemise en jean
[Musique]
ensuite il y a le refrain est là non ce
n'est pas possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne veux pas lui ressembler ce gamin
ne parle pas français
je veux bien qu'il soit jeune mais quand
même à 10 ans tu s'est exprimé le verbe
ressemble ayez n'existe pas suite du
refrain
[Musique]
tu rêves je crois c'est sûrement pas
sûrement pas non non il est lié
ceci n'est pas une phrase où est le cod
ou et la fin de la phrase parce que non
non vieillit ce n'est pas une fin de
phrase emmener ce gamin à l'école au
moins une fois dans sa vie s'il vous
plaît ah ben voilà là je préfère donner
stop stop stop à d'accord je comprends
mieux le mec a 24 ans et il va au ce2
tout s'explique tout est beaucoup plus
claire maintenant un dormir habillé tout
ça enfin non dans le clip ils disent que
le grand va à l'école
[Musique]
non non là je dis non
si vous avez suivi un petit peu au début
du clip
ils demandent dans la même chambre soit
le grand il fait chaud pas dans ce cas
il ya pas de problèmes pour dormir dans
la chambre du petit frère soit il paie
show avec le petit qui dort à côté je
trouve ça un petit peu glauque quand
même maîtresse
un peu plus loin dans le clip vous allez
me dire s'il n'y a rien qui vous choque
et j'en suis fier
m
je crois sûrement par demont passionnant
je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un galères et
autant à mettre une veste
[Musique]
j'aimerais terminer sur le nom des
chanteurs bon bah déjà le gamin
s'appelle les eaux comme 50% des enfants
qui sont nés en 2001 je rappelle que les
autres 50% s'appelle enzo voilà y avait
que deux prénoms en 2001 restrictions
budgétaires et le grand s'appelle caries
fico je suis désolé mais gary c'est le
nom de l'escargot dans bob l'eponge et
fico basse et chico prononcée par un mec
qui zozote dire que je pensais avoir un
prénom pourri j'aurais pu m'appeler gary
fico quoi si vous ne pouvez pas vous
blairer cette musique partager ma vidéo
sur facebook et rejoignez ma page
et puis vous pouvez aussi aller sur
cyprien point fr pouvoir toutes mes
autres vidéos et soyez content aurait pu
s'appeler gary fico
[Musique]